Lightsabers are the legendary weapon of
the jedi and sith both elegant and powerful
but one lightsaber is especially unique created
by the first mandalorian to be inducted into
the jedi order the darksaber featured an
angular black blade and rectangular hilt seen
as the symbol of mandalorian leadership
many have wielded this legendary saber
following the fall of the empire the darksaber
is now in new hands how did he acquire it
what are his plans for it all i know is that this
time the darksaber is properly where it belongs
this is my tool this is like my
right arm i'm so happy to have this
mandalorian october 30th season two mob gideon
says watch i am so excited to be with you today
i have got so many surprises that i'm blown away
well i have to tell you when i got the phone call
i was incredibly excited and blown away to be a
part of a world and a universe that has the most
villainous villains and the most heroic heroes to
me it's stepping into history and for me also it's
a wonderful show that really encompasses all of
the power of myth and so i jumped out of my skin
when i found out that john favreau wanted me to be
part of the show because it allowed me to realize
how important this particular series of movies and
now this live action television show is fans went
nuts specifically and especially when they saw
the tip of that angular blade of the darksaber
reveal itself through the door of my thai fighter
and me following my hand out they went crazy one
of my favorite moments of the show because of
the physicality of having to come out of that
burned out tie fighter but the heroic nature
and feeling of i've survived this crash and not
only that here's a little teaser and surprise for
you they hinted at it and certainly helped me to
understand how powerful it was and i had to learn
how to hold it properly how not to let my wrist
bend keep your wrist strong and normally if your
right hand you put your left hand on top if you're
left-handed you put your right hand on top and
you have to not break your wrist to get through
the stroke this weapon this tool will
do anything the thing is to let it go
is to let it get sweeping motions that allow it to
soar and it will do exactly what you want it to do
what i love is the the connection between the
sound of it because this sound is the sound
of the future it's the sound of moff gideon and
you know that you have something i want
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going to be my
new star wars the mandalorian season 2 video all
about the darksaber giancarlo esposito narrating a
whole bunch of history we'll get into that and the
episodes are starting this friday i'll be doing
videos for all the season two episodes just like
season one so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos and make sure
you enable alerts so you don't miss anything we'll
do a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for the mandalorian season 2
on the video so just starting with the big stuff
first giancarlo esposito narrates some of the
history of the darksaber gives us a preview for
what we're going to be covering during season 2 in
terms of star wars history including moff gideon's
personal backstory in the star wars universe we
already know a little bit about his history from
the easter eggs in season 1 and we know a lot
about the darksaber's history in the star wars
universe because of all the other series it's
tied up in the history of the mandalorians culture
and the show is literally all about mandalorians
as the title implies there are also a bunch more
mandalorian characters coming to season two like
katie sackoff's boca tan and boba fett but number
four the biggest thing about season two in the
darksaber isn't so much explaining its long-term
history in the star wars universe they'll do that
too but the bigger thing is explaining where
moff gideon got it from or who he got it from
because turning the timeline of events the things
that we know already sabine wren a mandalorian
from the star wars rebels series gave it to bo
katan crees a couple years before the events of
star wars episode iv a new hope the whole reason
that she gave it to her was so that she could use
it to help unite the remaining mandalorian clans
under a single banner as the rebellion was finally
taking shape and the empire was still in the
process of going around subjugating the galaxy
after the events of the prequels in revenge of
the sith so if you go back and you watch the clone
wars season seven episodes from earlier this year
that's why boca tan doesn't have the darksaber
during this period most of that period during the
clone wars several years before the events of star
wars rebels it was actually darth maul who had
the darksaber even though you don't actually see
him wielding it right here he took it from john
favreau's character pre vizsla a couple years
earlier the leader of the death watch mandalorians
who we actually saw in a flashback scene from the
mandalorian season one notice the crest on all
their armor this is the death watch mandalorians
rescuing a very young din jarrin although we don't
know if prix vizsla himself was here for this
particular event pri vizsla played by jon favreau
john favreau the showrunner on the mandalorian who
also did the voice of the infantryman mandalorian
in live action who was also a member of the vizla
clan the circle of cameos is now complete but
then during the clone wars period after darth
maul took the darksaber from previzula he used his
crime syndicate to take over the entire planet of
mandalore occupy it then during one of the final
arcs in the clone wars season 7 they covered the
siege of mandalore event and that was when ahsoka
took a company of clone troopers and helped boko
tan and her loyalists retake the planet from maul
all the animation was totally on point it was
amazing the reason why you didn't see darth maul
using the darksaber during this fight with ahsoka
was because during this period he had actually
taken it back to dathomir so the darksaber is
basically chilling out with the nightsisters
till the events of star wars rebels when they
went to pick it up but the really cool easter egg
also from behind the scenes here too is that they
actually did motion capture for this fight on star
wars the clone wars bringing ray park back to do
darth maul motion capture he's also supposed
to be a character during the star wars obi-wan
kenobi series that's going to take place during a
period when darth maul was still alive but after
the events of the clone wars season seven episodes
so i'll cover all that stuff when we start getting
previews for that star wars ob1 series that's
all kind of separate from what's happening on
the mandalorian but because it's all happening
within the star wars timeline before the events
of the mandalorian we might see some easter eggs
for future mandalorian stuff so we pick up with
the darksaber during star wars rebels that's
when ezra bridger darth maul go to retrieve it
and eventually it winds up in the hands of
sabine wren who then gives it to beau katan
and even though there was a post credit scene in
the star wars rebels finale that takes place right
after the events of return of the jedi just a
couple years before the events of the mandalorian
season 1 tv series there was a time jump during
that episode where you basically a couple years
before the events of a new hope but then in that
post-credits scene you basically jumped to return
of a jedi so they skip over all the events
of the original trilogy and they don't tell
you what happened to boca tan the mandalorians
or the darksaber they only give you some hints
during the mandalorian season one but that's
all part of the history that they're going to
get into on the mandalorian season two because
moffgetty had already teased that he was working
for the imperial security bureau near mandalore
the planet during the events of the great purge
which happened after this moment in rebels but
before the events of return of the jedi the
great purge is basically when the emperor pulled
another version of order 66 on the mandalorian
people when they refused to bow to his will
enjoying the empire like the rest of the galaxy
that's when they started living in all these
sleeper cells hidden all over the outer rim
planets and that's how we get to boba fett and
katie sackhoff's live-action version of boca tan
during the mandalorian season 2 trailer they
released a little while ago the mandalorian
is talking to someone saying that if he can find
other mandalorians in the outer rim maybe they can
help him find the remaining jedi who are alive
during this period in history that's obviously
also a teaser for the ahsoka tano reveal as well
because she is the jedi that he's looking for
technically obviously part of different storylines
because boba fett is mostly localized to all the
tatooine stuff that we see in the trailers
bogatan is probably more connected to what's
going on with the ahsoka storyline the mandalorian
season 2 episode 1 is coming this friday all my
episode videos will post every friday just like
season 1 episodes they're eight episodes total
one per week so the season finale will be around
mid-december all the avengers wandavision episodes
are supposed to be released after the mandalorian
season 2 and i'll be doing videos for that as well
so there's a lot of really big stuff coming up
but there might be a couple more big trailers this
week so whatever ends up happening of course i'll
do videos for it marvel also just announced that
oscar isaac star wars person from the star wars
movies is going to be their new moon knight for
the moon night disney plus series so he's jumping
from the star wars universe to the marvel universe
i'll be doing a video for that it should post in
the next day or so but everyone click here for the
full mandalorian season 2 trailer in easter eggs
and click here for my new spider-man 3 sinister
6 teaser video in easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!